President Biden's dumpster fire at the
border getting even more dangerous as
Joe gets ready to open the floodgates by
ending title 42. new numbers show border
agents encountered 221 000 migrants in
March that's a highest monthly total in
more than 22 years border officials are
warning that number will explode in May
when Biden officially pulls the plug on
the Trump era policy that comes as
officials reveal to Fox News that nearly
two dozen known or suspected terrorists
were caught trying to cross illegally
into the country last year the White
House downplaying that report earlier
2000 illegal immigrants a day got away
last month are you saying that you can
say with certainty none of them are on a
terror watch list here's what we're
talking about encounters we know and of
suspected terrorists tempting across the
southern border they're very uncommon
these 23 people the border patrol they
stop them
that's our very own peter Ducey anyway
uh I think he also asked uh Jen whether
or not the president would be
apologizing to the Border agent he had
smeared by basically accusing him of
whipping Haitian migrants and calling
him a racist and whatnot shall I roll
that and then come to you for a reply
response or just your thoughts that's a
great idea all right let's do that
we've been told that the mounted border
patrol officers president accused of
whipping migrants have been notified
they will not face criminal charges so
when is the president going to apologize
to them there is a process and an
investigation that's gone through the
Department of Homeland Security I don't
have any update on that
um Dana I smell a rat how hard is it to
say I'm sorry if you go back into that
day it was in September of last year and
you watch the video and then you see
what happened that afternoon within
moments people who are familiar with
horses and with the work that they're
doing like no no they went with me and
that's how you use the reins in order to
maneuver the horse you can see the video
right there
um by that afternoon they could have
done that instead for the next like four
or five days they kept saying it more
and more the media absolutely piled on
then the president said that believe me
they're going to face consequences for
their actions so then majorcus has to do
this investigation they slow walk the
investigation they put these guys who
are out and about out doing their jobs
now have they been on desk duty while we
have a migrant crisis yeah and you
remember that book everything I need to
know I learned in kindergarten it still
applies right it's still a great book
for those Millennials out there you
gotta you gotta buy this book you have
to ask yourself what is the right thing
to do here the right thing to do is to
apologize yeah and to express regret
and if they were to do that and be
willing to do that this story would go
away
every day that they're not willing to do
that people are going to continue
talking about it and it's not just
because of this particular incidence
it's because it's a metaphor for all the
other things and one of those is that
consistently across all of the polls one
of the things that Biden pulls low in is
this question of does the president care
about things that you care about does he
is he does he have your best interest of
Mind does he think about your ideas and
your values and those numbers are very
low yeah something like this could help
them I don't think that they're I don't
think they would suffer too much and
then media is what they're going to
cover an apology for five days no
they'll cover it for five seconds but
that if they were to apologize they
could get it over with judge as uh from
your legal expertise is there a legal
reason why they want to apologize you
think maybe because that would open them
up not unless arrogance is a legal
reason they're arrogant they don't think
they have to a pile apologize look look
at what they're doing to this country
you've got 220 000 who came through the
Border in March all right they're
looking to get rid of title 40 to which
allows the US to turn away those people
that we think might be a problem given
the health problem that we have or had
in this country so uh now what they want
to just say is look it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter we're just going to
change the country we don't care what
you think whether it's whether or not
you think that that we think you're
racist or whether or not you think that
we should put criminals in jail or
whether or not you think that there
shouldn't be border security and I just
want to say one thing about that that
I'm tired of hearing that the border is
broken it's not broken the immigration
laws are not broken people just don't
want to follow them that's like me
saying you know what the United States
Supreme Court refused to hear the
assault argument by those of the people
paying taxes in New York New Jersey in
California and you know therefore the
the tax laws are broken they're not
broken they just are the way they are
and so would they say I'm sorry I don't
know not they're not going to but can
they sue is the real question so can
those guys have been referred to as
racist and and and and spinning around
with their so-called whips which are
nothing more than split Reigns yeah they
could sue they'll lose their job but
they can sue will they win probably not
sovereign immunity maybe they could go
after a newspaper and then say that the
newspaper will say we were relying on
the government well yeah put a Polish
admin uh Jessica you were nodding along
you apparently agreed with everything
the judge said every single word no
um I was thinking about how big this
country is while everyone talks about
these issues and that it's impossible to
understand the experience of
280 million other people at any moment
or 300 million whatever it is and like
when we talked about that story in
September I had to admit that I do not
ride horses often I have not thrown
rains around and I haven't visited the
border and
people need to have
like a little more empathy or just
kindness towards each other for their
experiences and I think that we would
end up in a lot in a lot better place
from that like we fundamentally I think
have similar feelings about immigrants
that they are good people
yep in the vast majority you want to
come here who want to work who want to
pay taxes if we give them the
opportunity and we see that in polling
time and time and time again that they
want a legal Pathway to citizenship and
then people are fine with it and you
know I was listening to Mark Kelly who
obviously has been a tough race and he
said I don't want title 42 gone until
there are solutions and it feels like
this might be a moment before we get to
2024 which is going to be terrible like
every presidential election is where we
could come up with a few solutions that
now that everyone has admitted that 220
000 per month coming across the borders
too many and I
I feel like there can be progress I hope
you're right what do you think John uh
first off I think that the White House a
mission accomplished they were able to
get every News Network for a week to
cover the horse whipping story and no
one is going to cover the fact that it
actually wasn't true so that was
accomplished border patrol is really bad
and I I keep asking the question why are
they opening the Border why are they
letting 121 000 people come across the
border and I don't know the answer to
that but I just know it helps the
cartels it helps pedophiles who want to
molest little kids it helps Xi Jinping
in China who wants to sell drugs into
our country it helps terrorists who want
to organize and come into America in 911
you actually had to get a visa and dupe
our system to get in now you just go to
Mexico and come across the southern
border none of this helps America and I
don't understand the strategy behind
what uh what Biden's doing because it
doesn't help Americans so the question
is what is Biden's end goal right how
many people come through when does it
ever end why is he doing it how many
people out there deserve to be in the
United States every one from the
southern hemisphere I mean that's the
question we do have millions of open
jobs and there are people who are coming
over who will do jobs that Americans
will not do and Republicans and
Democrats all profit off of
undocumentedly by not securing the
Border it makes legal immigration that
much harder and that is it's a real
frustration for those of us here and
there's many of us at this channel but
certainly at this table that have said
we want more immigrants to come we want
a legal process that's all yeah right
exactly yeah it's a process I agree with
you and I agree that we must move on we
must excellent hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else